good evening and welcome I'm Donna
McPhee I graduated from Columbia College
in 1989 and I'm the vice president for
alumni relations and president of the
columbia alumni association and i'm
pleased to be here to welcome you on
behalf of the CAA and the university
before we get started with the program i
just like to take a couple of minutes to
talk about the CAA and the columbia
alumni community we have almost 300,000
alumni worldwide and the CAA is
connecting all of you through the school
specific programs and through university
wide initiatives the energy and
enthusiasm from the alumni community is
happening on campus in new york city and
all over the world alumni are connecting
through events and programs like this
through Facebook through LinkedIn
through email and so much more some of
our fall highlights include our CAA
assembly weekend alumni panel it
occurred in New York City was moderated
by president Bollinger and featured
prominent alumni the topic this year was
unlocking creativity and some of the
alumni included Brian Dennehy and Tom
KITT who recently won the Tony and the
pulitzer prize for the broadway show
next to normal we also had pregame
festivities at home coming this fall and
over 1500 alumni and their families
participated in activities under a big
tent we had carnival games and it was
really just a joyous celebratory event
for the alumni we are busy planning for
this coming weekend's CA event in miami
it's in conjunction with the art basel
contemporary art fair we're planning for
Sundance in park city utah and we've
received the inside scoop that some of
our alumni have been selected to
showcase their films at the festival in
january we have over age 80 regional
programs around
world and alumni are connecting with the
help of alumni leaders like several who
are here tonight we recently had the
worldwide networking event it occurred
in 70 cities around the world and over
2,700 alumni participated we're looking
forward to the spring to connecting
alumni once again through the Columbia
community outreach program that not only
connects alumni with each other but
connects back with the students on
campus who will be participating in
projects in New York City we also have
our reunions that's the opportunity for
you to come back to campus so when it's
your time to celebrate your reunion year
please come back to campus and while
you're participating in the activities
visit us in the columbia alumni center
it is your home on campus it opened
almost two years ago and it features a
library a lounge come grab a cup of
coffee speak with fellow alum beat
Colombians seek colombiana in our
library and their staff there to help
you to navigate the campus alumni are
not only connecting with each other the
connecting back with the University and
we're so happy to say that they are
alumni are so enthusiastic that almost
90,000 alumni have participated in our
Columbia campaign and have donated we
are almost at the goal of four billion a
year ahead of schedule we're very
thankful for all you do for staying
connected and we can urge you to
continue to be part of our vibrant
alumni community I would like to point
out a senior administrator from New York
City who's with us tonight Fred Van
Sickle on January one he will be the new
executive vice president for university
development and alumni relations welcome
Fred
now I would like to introduce another
alum Ben Horowitz a Northern Californian
a true Colombian and a fixture in
Silicon Valley a berkeley high school
graduate been graduated in 1988 been
graduated in 1988 from Columbia College
with a major in computer science
following a master's in computer science
at UCLA he began his career at Lotus
Development Corporation before moving on
to senior positions at Netscape followed
by co-founding ops where in 1999 he
further served as the head of business
technology optimization unit at
hewlett-packard in 2009 together with
colleague mark anderson been founded the
venture firm andreessen horowitz which
has recently received prominent mention
in the new york times among other
publication publications Ben's father
David is a class of nineteen fifty-nine
college graduate Ben and his wife
Felicia have three daughters Mariah
Sofia and Julia who is a senior at the
college majoring in Spanish and
linguistics please welcome Ben Horowitz
alright thank you thank you very much I
am here to introduce liban her and Bill
Campbell two friends of mine and two
people who I'm very proud and privileged
to have the honor of introducing Lee I
graduated graduate of Columbia Law
School is the president of Columbia
University and one of the nation's most
thoughtful and original scholars of the
First Amendment he has received numerous
awards and honors for his writings in
public actions defending freedom of
speech and press he is also well known
for his leadership in successfully
defending affirmative action and
diversity in American higher education
which the United States Supreme Court
upheld in 2003 his books include the
tolerant society freedom of speech and
extremist speech in America images of a
free press and externally vigilant free
speech in the modern era and I'd like to
add that you know from my perspective in
observing presidents of Columbia since I
was a student the thing that Lee brings
to the University that is so different
and so incredible is leadership across a
broad variety of issues and you know you
could see it at University of Michigan
where he was president and he led the
nation to coming to the right outcome on
affirmative action but then at Columbia
be it the capital campaign which is the
the largest and most ambitious in the
university's history or making the
university truly global these kinds of
initiatives are just things that you
know that we've grown accustomed to but
there are quite remarkable and just
great to have him here as a president
Bill Campbell graduated from Columbia
with a BA in economics and
also a master's in teaching he was the
football coach at Columbia for six years
before going into the business world and
his players will say he was a very good
coach his record says a pretty good
coach he went on yeah and he was built
remarkable thing about Bill as he was
you know his in his late 30s when he
moved from coaching into business but
had a stunningly successful business
career starting as an executive at Kodak
and then at Apple and moving on to
become the chief executive officer of a
company called go which was basically
building the iphone in 1992 which was
too early by the way and in technology
being too early is not good but he we
you know despite the fact that he was
way too early people recognized his
leadership skills and he became CEO of
into it which he built from 1994 to 1998
into one of the most important software
companies in the world which is you know
just an amazing story going from
football coach to CEO of a spectacular
disasterous thing at go just because it
was too early to building one of the
most important software companies in the
world and it just shows a lot about
bills character and the type of person
he is and then since then since into it
he's become a legend and they feel that
I'm in technology for and he's known as
kind of the coach again in helping
develop CEOs and the CEO some of the
CEOs he's helped develop steve jobs at
apple Eric Schmidt at Google Jeff Bezos
at amazon recently dick costolo at
twitter so these are some of the best
CEOs in the world and and some of the
best companies in the world and it's in
that capacity that that I actually met
bill where he helped develop me as CEO
when I was CEO of ops were and I can
tell you from that
that he hates the being called coach in
the context of helping CEOs and so the
reason I column coach is not just to
make him mad which I do like to do but
but to explain you know the reason that
bill doesn't like to be called coach is
because you know for him coaching mean
something it means like teaching people
how to block and tackle teaching them
how to play the game taking them through
the fundamentals the kinds of things
that coaches do which isn't quite what
he does in his new role but there are
things that coaches do that he does do
that I think are very applicable to both
CEOs and his work as chairman of the
board of trustees of Columbia and that
is Bill enables people to be their best
and you can see that in the people he
works with in technology and I see that
in what he does at the University and
everybody who's around bill everybody
who knows him they're just a little
better than they are when he's not there
and he really enables that and then
people who played for him and people
have worked with them really know that
and it makes me so proud to be part of
it and when I talk to people and the
other thing that great coaches do is
when you when you play for them it's
your team it's not their team it's your
team and when you work for them it's not
their company it's your company and
everybody who worked at go it goes their
company and everybody who works you know
in the companies that bill works for it
you know Google is their company and
twitter is their company and F Columbia
what I've noticed since bill has been
chairman of the board of trustees is
people really feel like it's their
University that it's yeah and I feel
like Columbia is my university and so I
would just say that I'm very proud to
introduce Bill Campbell and Lee
Bollinger who who make me proud that
Columbia is my University thank
up there and I didn't first thing you
have to notice is has it been jumped up
from there and Lee and I walked around I
don't know if that was an IQ test or a
statement about age but I wanted to jump
a bill said we had to walk up my
standard those couple artificial hips
not quite worked out well then thank you
for your for your introduction of both
of us and I am deeply thankful for your
participation as an alumnus that in our
university so we've got an opportunity
to and we'll leave some of the questions
open for the audience it certainly had a
at part of the time but I've got some
topics that I'd like to probe Lee about
and I think the most important one from
my standpoint has been Lee's been he's
in his ninth year as present University
and the trustees unanimously supported
providing him with additional five years
on his term and you know it's a
contracted at least that the the world
that we live in today is almost
unprecedented but our view of our trusty
view of him has been that he is the
leader that we want today is the leader
that we want tomorrow so I just wanted
to ask you you know your thoughts about
new contract what that means about your
commitment and how you see the
university moving forward well so let me
also begin by thanking all of you for
coming and bill for doing this and it's
really terrific and well obviously open
this up and have lots of conversations
about lots of things I mean for me the
simple answer to Bill's question is we
have so many things going on right now
at the University that we've started
over the past eight nine years that need
another five years to really
complete not so much to complete but to
make them a permanent sort of feature of
the University that it just seemed right
from my standpoint and right from other
people standpoint so what that really
means I think in a very concrete sense
is the the new campus Columbia has been
as we know absolutely starved for space
and they're just so many ways in which
the university has actually suffered by
not having the kind of space to grow and
expand and universities are places that
build new knowledge and as you build new
knowledge it takes more laboratories
that takes more classrooms it takes more
students takes more faculty that's just
the nature of what universities do and
if you cannot expand you cannot become a
truly great place and we've got this new
campus 18 acres six million square feet
take 50 years to build out we never
would have thought we would be there 10
years ago and now we have that and and
we're just at this moment completing and
opening next week the last building on
Morningside Heights northwest corner
building inelegantly called that but
it's on the northwest corner and it's
for interdisciplinary science that that
completes Morningside Heights one of the
great academic spaces in the world and
we are simultaneously the trustees
approved the first building on the new
campus in manhattanville of mind brain
behavior institute and that will open in
five years hence my desire to stay for
five more years but there are lots of
other things we can talk so
manhattanville unless they have an
unhandled for a second and you know what
that has meant your vision you know
there were a lot of times when you would
admonish me and to also push the
trustees to say we can't check it out on
this we've got to do this and when a lot
of the things occurred with the city etc
some of the regulatory approvals that
were required there you know you had you
had your head down and you made
or that you did everything that it took
is is manhattanville I mean is it that
is it does it save Columbia from you
know that the physical constraint that
that would that's collapsed many so I
over the universities I think the answer
is yes I think it is it is the place for
new energy that will affect both
Morningside Heights Washington Heights
lamont-doherty the offices and places
were setting up around the world it is
manhattanville that is the sort of
seminal thing for the institution and
and it's you know Harvard has Alston and
one of the things about Austin is that
nobody wants to move there and you can't
get the law school to you know Larry
Summers went over to the law school they
didn't want to move he went elsewhere at
Columbia there is a pent-up need for new
space and new facilities and so in phase
one which will go through 2015 we have
the my brain behavior initiative and an
institute we have the School of the Arts
small building for it larger building
across the street we have an academic
conference center which we don't have at
Columbia place to really have major
meetings school of international public
affairs will have a building and the
business school may have just read Henry
Kravis committed a hundred million
dollars towards this new project and so
the business school will move that URIs
which is you know not the greatest
building in the world will then be
available for other programs
international programs and so it will
help that it will help uptown it is
critical so there you know we got a lot
of criticism you know over the years and
yet the US News and World Report get the
famous or infamous you know ranking
systems about you know the lack of space
and
on on campus in and then certainly the
business school this last year you know
remarkably we were named number four
right and universities in the US News
and World Report survey I know because I
was there I watched you put together a
plan that suggested that we wanted to be
back in the top five and the validation
was I think enormous you know the
trustees were you know it very
enthusiastic about it whether we like
that survey or whether we don't at least
this year it's it suited our need we
like it we like it sure we like it okay
talk about your thought process of that
of that long-term strategy that you put
in place and how you course-correct
every year to ensure that that the
university is on track to get achieved
that top five well i mean first of all
let me just say it's great it's
fantastic working with Bill on these
overall ambitions for the university
just great and and the trustees have
been just so supportive and helpful and
a really well functioning board and that
makes all the difference in the world
and and faculty deeply committed to all
of these ventures the basic outline is
Columbia has to be known as one of the
top five or six universities in the
world it just has to be a given and
that's essentially Harvard Yale Columbia
put Princeton and even though Princeton
is significantly undergraduate I think
it's Stanford I believe Berkeley is
underrated in the set of national
rankings I think Berkeley is one of the
great institutions in the country but
Chicago I mean these are these are the
corn Columbia's got to be there for
Columbia to be there it has to do a
number of things has to solve the space
problem which we have it's been raised
owned it's ready to go it's a
credible moment only happens once a
century and and we're ready to build
resources and that starts with trustees
and because trustees have to give an
order for other people to give and the
trustees have done that the four billion
dollar capital campaign was mentioned
that's was unthinkable for Columbia
10-15 years ago it's the largest capital
campaign goal in the United States other
than Stanford's at 4.25 we will finish
at that four billion dollar goal a year
at a time even with the recession and
that's a tribute to the alums it's in a
tribute to the parents and to the people
who support Columbia we will shortly
announce that we're going to continue
the capital campaign and for another two
years and we'll have a bigger
announcement to go along with that
another factor on the resources side ten
years ago we were 13th in the country in
actual dollars in capital campaigns
count future gifts promises a future
gifts but the actual dollars in we were
13th in the country and in that for the
past five six years we have routinely
been in the top five and that's where we
should be we're usually third right
behind Harvard and not right behind
Harvard and Stanford but third and
number right behind but Harvard is a
hundred million dollars more we're about
400 to 500 million a year being raised
that's how supportive people are of
Columbia now Harvard's about 600 million
and Stanford's about 700 million so
that's really good news because that
means that there's a 200 million dollar
hole there that we can quickly fill and
and we could use it so resources then
you have to build the academic programs
because all this only matters if you
have great faculty and great students so
all this is just to make that happen
and people have been working on the
undergraduate on the college and Gemma
set for several decades and it's and
we've worked on it and it's paying off
and and to have US news ranking the
university fourth among national
universities is a great sign of how far
we've come so one of the hallmarks of
your tenure there has been fiscal
responsibility and I think in the past
people have felt that the university has
been frivolous and didn't operate itself
well and you know for more i sit and i
know you have felt very strongly about
the caliber of people that you brought
into to run the university and you know
one of them the great turnarounds has
been medical center etc so talk a little
bit about the importance of you know how
you're managing budgets and you know how
strong you are on articulating defined
goals financially for your team well let
me start with again with the trustees I
when I started a decision had already
been reached to take the endowment and
to put it in a professional management
it was the trustees and the president
and the CFO will sit on the board but up
to that point it had been a subcommittee
of the trustees you don't want basically
you don't want trustees and the
university administration running the
endowment it should be something so and
that has really paid off so in the
downturn we were down sixteen percent
whereas other places were down thirty
percent and we came back seventeen
percent in the next year I mean overall
were eight nine percent I think we've
done extremely well the only the only
University that was close to us in terms
of yeah in endowment return and lack of
losses was University of Pennsylvania
the rest of them were in there yep low
to mid 30s yes and we were and our
recovery of course has been as lisa has
been festers and then as soon as we saw
the downturn we said we're going to plan
for the worst
and I immediately cut my budget ten
percent and and other people cut there's
ten percent and we really took immediate
action and then because we weren't so
dependent on the endowment in part
because our endowment smaller than our
competitors but also because we haven't
really relied on it in the same way
because we took quick action word we're
now in a period of growth we kept the
ambition while the world has made
everybody struggle more broadly I mean I
my view is you try to get people who
really are strong very very good and
smart people and and I I prize that in
the administration and then I helped
them and I support them and I criticized
them and and like and we brought in li
Goldman from here CSF yep UCSF and it
may have been your doctors for some of
you because he was chair of internal
medicine here and he's done just a great
job bringing financial stability to to
the Medical School of the Health
Sciences and Robert Kasdan has done this
in the university and so we've really
managed I think our resources well so
you know when you think about it you
know you have people on the fundraising
side Fred and and you know before him
Susan begging me for France is in fig in
one of the you know the great great
performers and that we've ever added
Columbia legal men Robert Kasdan you've
surrounded yourself with terrific people
and and it's paid off and for all of you
who who really have struggled you know
with your businesses through this
economic downturn Columbia has done the
same thing struggled but managed itself
beautifully well under Lee's leadership
so let's talk a little bit more about
you know gonna mention CAA again that
was another thing that you brought to
the University you know that there had
been a small number of people that
contributed large sums of money to the
well-being of the University your view
was that the columbia alumni association
should be one
interconnection you know having people
feel very close to and understanding the
workings of the University and and
sharing and it's its intellectual
benefit and you know this today is you
know under Donna's leadership has turned
out to be a you know phenomenal
organization you know I you've obviously
seen this kind of thing work before the
other grassroots level where we're not
mentioned in everybody's pocket we want
to make sure that what we're looking for
our people that care a lot about the
university yep and we've tried i think
the way to put it is we tried to change
the character of what it means to be a
student and alum apparent a supporter a
part of the community faculty of
columbia we tried to change that
character so i think we all know
everybody in this room who has been part
of columbia for many decades as has been
true for me and bill and and i can see
many here you all everybody knows that
Columbia had a reputation for not being
an easy place to go to school and it
didn't stay in touch with you afterwards
and it didn't you know it was not that
kind of warm really friendly connected
kind of institution and there are a
variety of justifications for it New
York City it's tough you got to come and
you know you got to make it losing in
sports is actually a positive and and
you know that doesn't matter school had
very successful then and school spirits
a you know something that's almost
anti-intellectual main it's a and so all
that's wrong I mean oh that's completely
completely wrong and and so it was and
because the university had struggled so
much in the nineteen coming out of the
the events of 1968-69 how whatever you
think about
what happened then the fact of them and
i was there in 1968 the fact of the
matter is no university was hurt more by
what happened in 1968-69 than columbia
and that's 4,000 police coming in the
middle of the night and and it just was
a really traumatizing event and that was
followed by the utter decline of New
York City in the 1970s and Columbia was
a tough place to be just like New York
City was a tough place to be so by 1980
when Mike sovereign became president he
had to start rebuilding an institution
not from scratch but it was tough well
my view was we've got to make this a
feeling of a community and one of the
things that was true is that there was
no university-wide alumni assoc every
school had its own alumni they and you
couldn't identify if you wanted to be
part of the university and many of us do
there was no place to connect and so we
created the CAA and that's been a
stunning success and you've led this
bill and gotten trustees involved to
take it on and and been supportive of
this and then the athletics program
let's let's talk about that because I
felt you know it was inexcusable to have
a program where young people would come
in and the expectation would be that
they would lose and lose again and again
I mean it just that was unacceptable and
and so you you had to change the culture
in that and so we got a new athletic
director we begin to hire new coaches
supportive and you know bill has been
the person I would credit most with
tried with bringing the spirit the bill
has to to this among many other things
that he's done but the we're now in
terms of a B championships every year in
the middle of the IV pack and
them and you know that's that's good
we've got it is I mean we've won we won
more Ivy titles in the last three years
and we did the previous 35 and diane
murphy is our athletics director she has
been terrific and we are growing all of
our spoor getting better and better
honestly and the women's sports programs
have been outstanding yeah so are you
know we are football was formed six this
year men's basketball program is off to
a good start but it could have been six
and four very easily write it just lost
a few of you know it's true it's
absolutely true we've got our president
pay attention all this yeah yeah so you
know you talked a little bit about you
know the morale on campus and you know
there's a lot of people in here from
college undergraduate college
engineering etc you know how do you how
do you see the university supporting I
you know historically and I think Dave
our courts down here you know those of
us who who were there always felt that
the undergraduate got your trip to the
professional schools and and you know I
haven't heard that complaint you know
I've been at a trustee now eight years
and I haven't heard that complaint in
seven right because you support the
undergraduate tell me the importance
tell us at all about the importance of
undergraduate education and what you've
done to make sure that it has its own
you know strong feeling well I think the
way I try to put it is that it's like
it's like a parent and I know we don't
like to think about college students and
sort of a parent relation child
relationship with the university but but
I think that there is a an element of
that we are responsible for the
education and the well-being of these
very young people who come into our
community and you know it's a privilege
in fact because these will be people who
will go on to have major positions in
the world and influence the world and to
be with them in this formative period is
a great privilege but still it's our
responsibility
well and response yordan you're only as
good as how good you are to the youngest
people among you if you neglect the
youngest people in your community you
will not be a great University just
because you will not be a great person
and so I think it's critical and and
then there are things I mean I teach
undergraduate every year I teach a
course on First Amendment I do it with
undergraduates I do it in part to
symbolize the importance of teaching
undergraduates but I think we we know
the elements of the great success we
know that the core curriculum is
something that is unmatched anyplace
else and if you think I say it this way
nobody in this room I predict we'll go
home tonight and say boy am I tired i
think i'm going to get out Aristotle's
ethics and read one of the one of the
chapters to relax the the fact of the
matter is at age 18 and 19 you're
sitting in a small class with a gifted
faculty member and reading Aristotle's
ethics or montagnes essays or
Shakespeare play and you would never you
won't do that to have that experience
once in your life especially at that
formative moment is a truly
life-changing experience so more like
just memorable then you have I think
fantastic faculty who were very
committed at Columbia that Columbia has
a it's a research university some people
think there can't be that much attention
undergraduate there really is and then
you're in New York City and then there's
the fact that Columbia I think is the
most naturally global institution of any
university in the country and for a
young person in this world to be able to
be on a campus
where you can hear people who are
working in Africa and villages and how
extreme poverty are working on AIDS or
Sarkozy Xin to give a speech or you
could work on a project in Jordan
because we have a new center there or
you can go to debate I mean this is a
this is a for a young person that's
really unmatched and the proof is you
ask any undergraduate or you ask any
parent of an undergraduate any student
but I'm focusing now on undergraduates
and they will say incredibly happy right
so talk a little bit just very quickly
about you know you put a new dean and
charging in inner engineering school and
and you know they the acclamation of him
as a as a leader he's inspired a lot of
people to to be excited about
engineering on her campus again so this
is penny Oscar penny Mora who is
originally from the Dominican Republic
and spoke no English until at age 21 or
something he gave the United States with
his mother i believe and took a course
in english at riverside church i believe
is that right and them and top i did you
know it's and then went to MIT and then
went on to a very fine career as an
engineer as a faculty member and he's
come in he's very young and dynamic and
and has taken on how to make this very
small but wonderful with lots of
potential engineering school and applied
science and really advanced it and we've
settled on certain areas to emphasize
biomedical was clearly one we should be
great truly great in nanoscience another
very hot and for good reason area and
and several others computer science and
he's very hard to work at this he's got
a program
of raising money for a rising star
faculty and within the space of a year
he raised with the multiple chairs took
good you know they've least a couple of
buildings and put some entrepreneurial
startup opportunities they're a pretty
funny and so for those of us who from
silicon silicon valley he's had a big
reach out here and a lot of people that
are in this room tonight that are that
have engineering backgrounds from
Columbia have really been very very
helpful and going back there and
teaching some classes and being involved
the program so that's been positive
let's talk a little bit about the
professional schools you know that
obviously that you know the big three
that you know you you mentioned Lee
Goldman in medicine and then you've got
law and business as well let's talk
about you know those we I know we have a
lot of graduates in here from from those
three and and with this number for
ranking you know each of those has moved
up I think considerably and you know the
way they're viewed nationally well
they're they're great and really great
schools obviously and we've got
fantastic small schools but the
journalism school under nick lemon and
architecture school public health i mean
these are all fantastic places business
school first of all i think
manhattanville is very very important
and exciting opportunity for the
business school and have Henry and the
Board of Overseers of the business
school commit themselves to that project
is a is a great moment my own personal
view is that business schools should be
more central to the intellectual life of
universities and the reason I think that
is because I I believe like lots of
people believe that globalization sort
of defines the problems of our era the
interconnectedness that comes from
economic activity around the globe and
the interdependence II that that's
created and and the big project for this
century in a way is creating the
institutions that are needed to
to make that function in the best
possible way so we're trying to do it
with Basel 3 with financial regulation
trying to do it with climate change
we're trying to do it with international
terrorism we're trying to do it with
economic regulation I mean this is this
is the big big project and it happens
the really go Colombia's way because
we're in New York City and because we're
naturally international well the
business school should be the place in
the university that leads this
discussion and so I'm very very keen on
the Business School taking on greater
leadership Glenn Hubbard is the Dean of
the school and doing a fine job and very
much wants to move in this way and very
prominent course is a participant in
these debates law school I think also of
course great great institution but I
think it's in a very interesting stage
of kind of reshaping its intellectual
agenda generally I often say I am a
product of my time which is the the
1960s and 70s when I begin law teaching
and that era was defined I think by
American constitutional law every single
major problem we had in this country was
refracted through constitutional law in
some kind of way and people like me
sprouted up and and taught things like
the First Amendment became highly
specialized and now it's still important
to have constitutional law experts but
it's even more important to have
international trade law experts and
energy law experts and how do you build
legal institutions for this
interdependent economic system and the
law school is is really working in those
kinds of directions I think it's very
promising so talk a little bit more
about you have put you know after about
your third year there you took up you
know big initiative on globalization in
many cases you know kind of even scared
the faculty a little bit turn
of your views about how important the
globalization effort should be and
gradually not only won them over but
have them you know really participating
actively and what we're doing just talk
about that a little bit your view of the
importance of what you've done in in our
regional centers so building off what I
just said my general view is that
universities have a very very
significant scholarly responsibility and
educational responsibility to address
these issues that arise from this
phenomenal increase in economic
interdependence e as knows I sit sit on
the new york fed board a Federal Reserve
Bank board and will become chair and of
the board in January so I've had I been
on the board now for four years so I've
had a kind of certain perspective window
onto the global financial world and more
broadly I find it of interest when you
think about the American economy and
where it's going to go once we get out
of this particular severe downturn what
many people are counting on is the
Chinese consumer and the Indian consumer
and the Brazilian consumer now that's a
stunning thing to say if that's so and a
lot of people are saying this and it
sounds right how do we create the world
that makes that work in many of these
countries there is no rule of law no
rule of law we haven't really operated
in an economy in an economic system
without a rule of law for quite a long
time
what do we think about food safety what
do we think about product safety what do
we think about environmental issues how
are we going to grapple with these
things this is a fantastic opportunity
for Colombia because we're really good
at this and we can be really great at I
got lamont-doherty which has done some
of the finest work in the study of
oceans and climate change and glaciers
got the Earth Institute with Jeff Sachs
we've got Joe Stiglitz we've got on and
on and and this is something we can
really build on then you say well how do
you do this because how we got those
great people but and some great
institutions but how did we more broadly
do this so just to be very quick about
it there are three possible strategies
one is you can just do more of what you
already do send more students on study
abroad programs have more faculty come
in from around the world etc just do
more but that's one a second is the
setup branch campuses around the world
and NYU is now famously setting up one
in Abu Dhabi but in Qatar there already
a number of universities Carnegie Mellon
northwestern Texas A&M Cornell Medical
School who set up branch campuses in
Qatar and we have chosen not to do that
and there are a number of reasons for it
but basically the reason is that you can
only go where there's a lot of money
because whatever we do we lose money and
it's just too expensive to give the kind
of education we give and therefore
you've got to get supplemental money in
the only places that have it are places
like the Emirates the third is the set
up what we're calling centers they're
basically offices and some facilities
that are made available with very
sophisticated people running them very
connected and they are going to be
interconnected we've got them now in
four or five places in mumbai and mon
jordan beijing just opening one in
nairobi
and in Paris of course and these will
provide a network of support offices for
faculty and students to work around the
world and there'll be research projects
and conferences and meetings and so and
that's a short version of what we've
decided to do and is very I think very
quiet it's quite exciting I might add
you know I think you're pushing all of
the deans to incorporate global is it
courses that that really would stress
yeah international in the curriculum and
almost are in every school in the
university it is it's been remarkable to
see um i have i'm going to give you one
opportunity i hope you hope you seize on
this opportunity now i want to make sure
that yesterday George W was that he went
to Facebook and promoted his book well
you have a rather large audience here
won't you tell us a little bit about
your oh that's weird new book and you
have an opportunity yeah yeah yeahs to
see if you can't sell some III think I
think we're giving it away I don't not
like that hahaha well maybe see if they
buy it first yeah so I teach First
Amendment and that's been my field and
freedom of speech freedom of the press
my father my family worked and
newspapers my grandmother did my father
did owned a little newspaper I grew up
in Santa Rosa just north of here and
then when I was about 12 we moved to
Baker organ my father got this newspaper
so and I was the janitor eyes I've lived
around newspapers and cared about this
these issues the 20th century was when
we created freedom of speech and press
that we know today that's the very first
case in the Supreme Court of the United
States interpreting the First Amendment
wasn't until nineteen nineteen all
before that it was kind of there but but
we really didn't have what we think of
today as freedom of speech and press as
a constitutional dock
or the public policies like broadcast
regulation and the like WikiLeaks
publishes this stuff new york times
publishes at the guardian and so on this
is Pentagon Papers this is that's the
case that's relevant I know that case
inside and out teach it every year this
is my world New York Times versus
Sullivan and so on it's an elaborate
really complicated wonderfully
successful twentieth century invention
that we have in this country of freedom
of speech impress neo-nazis can march in
Skokie Washington Post can publish
classified documents you public
officials can't sue you if you make a
false statement about them that hurts
their reputation we got all these rules
and principles and doctrines and and so
on suddenly and literally suddenly we're
in a world where now the issues are
global and the communication system is
global because people like you and
others here and another have created
this instantaneous global communication
system and what that means is that you
now say something here you've now said
something to read something around the
world that means you may be prosecuted
not here because you've got First
Amendment rights but you may be
prosecuted in Turkey for offending
Turkish pneus which is a crime or sued
for libel in Britain because they got
very different approach to libel than
New York Times versus Sullivan or you
may be in trouble in in China or in
Singapore you may be criminally
prosecuted this is a new world with a
whole new set of challenges of how do we
develop free speech Free Press
principles on a global scale there's no
it's not as if there's nothing there
article 19 of the Universal Declaration
of Human Rights and coming out of World
War two and the UN is a wonderful
statement of global principles but it's
not been strengthened their regional
organization
institutions but we need to pay more
attention to this just like we need to
pay more attention to economic
institutions and then there's the issue
of how do we get the kind of information
we need and that the world needs not
just how do we get the free speech Free
Press principles but how do we get the
information well one of the things we
know is that the wonderful things you've
created here in Silicon Valley and
elsewhere have expanded the potential of
people to communicate but they've had a
devastating effect on our great
institutions of the press to be able to
keep their business model going so
foreign correspondents are a dying breed
foreign bureaus are a dying breed and
and you can buy Newsweek for a dollar I
mean that's incredible and and you can
have the Boston Globe for for probably
the same amount and that means we're
getting less international news and what
does that mean for us in this new world
meanwhile al Jazeera is funded by the
Qatari government and is expanding like
crazy and has a reach of I don't know 75
million and recent study found that
because the Miami Herald no longer
publishes anything I mean they no longer
have any foreign bureaus in South
America and bureaus in South America
basically been closed by US media al
Jazeera has been opening them like crazy
in South America and if you're sitting
in Washington DC and want to find out
something about South America a study
showed that that most people turn to Al
Jazeera now well you know what do we do
about what do we think about this
france24 Russia today I mean it's a
really interesting set of problems and
that's what I've begun to try to address
hahaha durden market nevermind I was
that's what I was going to say that's I
was gonna say sorry manhattanville goes
from a hundred and twenty fifth street
broadway and a hundred and twenty fifth
street to 130 third street over to the
west side highway was twelfth Avenue
which right on the river 18 contiguous
acres all rezone now and we own all the
property and nothin that's a little up
the road a little down the road when
when I was an undergraduate at Columbia
College in the mid-50s nobody but nobody
had ever heard of manhattanville had
ever even walked over to manhattanville
except for a few of us who went to a
Chinese restaurant on 29 3 i'm curious
what you've done for example with the
Borden's factory what the old Borden's
milk company factory over there building
which was the largest building in what
is now called manhattanville that's
unbelievable question well I'll tell you
what we've done with it if we're talking
about the same one it's the it's the
white tile building on the south side of
hundred and twenty fifth Street that's
it right that's it I mean just to show
you how the world changed we have a
tower apartment house that's right there
in one hundred and twenty fifth Street
right at the corner just down from that
milk factory in the 1970s that became so
dangerous that area that the entrance on
one hundred and twenty fifth Street was
closed and reopened on that little
street that goes up the hill by the
viaduct we are now reopening that
entrance where a lot of faculty live and
graduate student
opening that on one hundred and twenty
fifth Street that building you mention
is preserved we're going to keep it we
are renovating it the School of the Arts
is using it and will continue to use it
and that will anchor the south part of
the campus it's a lovely little building
in white because they wanted a symbol
that was used to pasteurized milk and
they wanted a symbol of purity and as on
and it's a and Renzo Piano who's the
master planner for manhattanville whom
we hired and will design the first three
or four buildings on the south side
declared that the little grandmother of
manhattanville and then the studebaker
building which is just there's a much
bigger building and it's about a hundred
and thirty fourth and in the midst of
all this and we agreed to preserve that
he called the grandfather and and they
sort of preside over over Manhattan
build but you know what just taking
those two buildings shows why this was a
great move for us for the community and
for the city and for the country they
don't make pasteurized milk in the board
and building anymore believe it or not
they were not making Studebakers in the
Studebaker building either and there's
another building on the corner which we
now own also a hundred and thirty third
and broadway on the east side called the
nash building and they don't make Nash's
there either this was a thriving
industrial little small industrial area
in the 20s 30s 40s and by the 60s 70s it
was on decline and by one of the reasons
we selected this area as the place for
Columbia to expand was because there
were only two hundred 150 or 200 people
who lived in those 18 acres and we
promised them at the beginning that they
would have better lives than then they
had then and that we would never use
eminent domain against residents
and we made huge commitments to the
surrounding communities and a Harlem
into the city to make this campus
something that will really integrate the
surrounding communities hi my name is
Matt Morales I'm a 2008 graduate of the
school general studies and now I'm a
Silicon Valley entrepreneur but one of
the things I noticed you know just in
2008 when I was graduating is the school
general studies which which has a unique
history in Columbia um a lot of my
classmates were graduating with insane
debt loads the average graduating debt
load which is truly mind-blowing was
ninety thousand dollars of debt for
bachelors from Columbia and myself I was
fortunate enough to be able to work two
jobs to pay my way through school and
also get scholarships and journalism
awards um but had I not had this up
these opportunities I would have been in
the ninety to a hundred thousand dollar
debt range and I was wondering what you
guys are doing to lower that to lower
that number which as an alumni just
seems insane and I see my friends now
you know these huge debt loads this is
still loan debt like you can that's you
can't you can't you can't get rid of it
it's not like a car or a house you III
don't want to make light of this but i
do want to give i want to give a very
quick and as comprehensive as I can't
answer to the question and is honest so
here goes point number one always
remember that the education at full
price that Columbia offers basically
cost twice as much to deliver as the
full tuition costs I mean that's that's
just a fact the reason Columbia can give
small classes and the core curriculum
and and all these guys I have a law
school and a business is because people
have given
funds to this endowment and continue to
give and there are other some other in
the sciences it's because of public
funding but at the end of the day it
costs twice as much to give the
education as a full price so always bear
that in mind nevertheless it's very
expensive and for people you know who
come from modest means or or not very
much means at all and families this is a
this is a huge issue and it's a huge
issue because we are a public
institution we're not public in the
sense of University of California
Berkeley or the University of Michigan
but we're public in just the same way
and that we're not out there to make
profit and we have a public trust that
perform and part of that public trust is
to make sure that we do as much as we
can for the American ideal which is that
a young person's education should not
depend upon the wealth of their family I
mean that's if American lives by certain
values have certain guys that's one of
its its top ones because we you know
otherwise we've got an aristocracy and
plutocracy well Third Point Columbia
College comes about as close to reaching
the ideal as any place in the United
States probably in the world if you
family makes less than sixty thousand
dollars you come free to columbia now
we've increased the financial aid we
loans for families making a hundred and
twenty thousand dollars i mean i'm sorry
grant we only give grants not loans so
the financial aid picture and we put a
huge amount of resources because we
don't have enough endowment to match our
commitments in the in the college but we
have substantial endowments to build on
and we have substantial opportunities
for raising funds for the college if you
go to the professional schools the
problem is different the
problem is not how do you pay for it
getting it's the problem of life choices
so a law school we charge 40 thousand
dollars a year to go to law school you
can't afford that if you're going to go
work at cravath swaine and more or
another major law firm that that is not
a big problem in in life but if you want
to go do public interest law that's a
big problem because you're not going to
be able to to pay that back so that's
our problem there we have very good but
not as good as we want loan forgiveness
programs then we go to general studies
so we don't have nearly the same kind of
financial aid for general studies that
we do for the college and the general
studies is a thousand students who are
very very important to Columbia and
valuable to the country not all people
develop at age 17 into the gifted people
we admit the thousands of people who
apply to columbia college some people
struggle in life and then become
brilliant at age 30 some people go off
and become dancers and some people do
this and that and we provide a program
to capture to give opportunities to
people like that a lot of veterans one
of the we're very proud of the number of
veterans I think we have 200 300
veterans in the undergraduate program at
Columbia so how does that happen well
universities are built on have been
built on historical a ton autonomy for
individual schools and departments and
on part of that autonomy is that they
can keep what they raise and the college
raises has raised a lot more over time
than general studies and the law school
has raised a lot more over time than the
journalism school and the business
school has raised a lot more and has
much more acts
to wealth then the School of the Arts
and so there is within universities a
serious differential in the ability to
support people to come in and not to
graduate with with major burdens we all
know we inherit institutions that are
complex and and something is large and
and as complicated as a university you
don't just come in and say well we're
going to change all that and the college
has to give a hundred million dollars of
its endowment to general studies I mean
that's just not the way these
institutions work but what we've tried
to do is to put money our own resources
into general studies and we've done that
I think significantly and we've made
very special efforts to try to raise
financial aid on part of general studies
PT ron has been terrific in in doing
this and but we're not we're not close
to where we should be it's like a couple
more questions uh yeah mr. Bollinger
where are you I here I hey Ted Sonny and
jun 06 you spoke on two themes the
recession and globalization with those
Chinese Indians and Brazilians in the
developing world coming online years to
come and recession with an unemployment
of about ten percent how do you feel
education responds in the United States
more specifically Columbia and liberal
arts education to a more competitive job
environment to prepare Columbia
graduates in that environment well
that's a big question that an important
one I would of course my view I bet is
the same view we have everybody in this
room there's no better way to prepare
for a lifetime of employment than to do
a liberal arts education by which we
mean non-specialized but I think that
there are things that we have to do to
help young people become even more
prepared and
and so what would those be one I think
we've segmented our knowledge too much I
use the law as an example I think it's
great that we have law schools fantastic
i love them but law should be taught
more to undergraduates and there's no
reason why law should be a subject that
should be viewed as professional and the
like and so I enjoy teaching First
Amendment I to undergraduate I'd do it
exactly the way I do in a law school I
think so i think there's room for the
business school to teach undergraduates
and in fact they've got a program doing
them this is not to be professional
about it but i think Public Health we're
getting trying to get more into the
undergraduate opera education I think
the other thing I would say is that we
really need to help our students
experience the world if we are not we
are in a time when actually going to
Beijing are going to Mumbai or going to
a small village in Kenya is is critical
to a young person's sense of potential
learning I mean we all know this very
odd experience where you travel
someplace you never been there before
and suddenly start reading every article
in the paper about this place and you
you learn about it there's something
that that triggers in your mind the
little experience you've had that makes
it a fantastic learning experience for
for life you feel connected to it we
need to have lots of opportunities for
our students to get out there and just
to see what's going on in the world and
then build that into their education and
I think all those things will will be
important I think also bringing more
people from around the world to campus I
happen to believe that
and we will be in a internationally
competitive world within 10 years for
undergraduate education so my view is we
don't care whether we just want the most
brilliant young mathematician and we
don't care what the person comes from
Pakistan or Belarus or and and there'll
be more of that kind of competition
right now I think we're at nine or ten
percent under international students at
the at the college I'll bet we'll be at
fifteen percent in 10 years and and and
more so let's take one more question and
I'm getting hook here go ahead I will
take both glad you start and you finish
well I think Barack Obama is you know
there's kind of nothing better than
having the president united states a
graduate of your institution so so I you
know I think it makes us all feel really
good and that's great and and and I'm
not I mean it'd be easy to say I think
he is who he is because he he studied at
Columbia and maybe took some of the core
curriculum he came late I think that
would be kind of funny I think I think
he is obviously an extraordinary
individual and the fact that he is part
of our community is makes us all feel a
little more extraordinary but that's
true I mean that that's a legitimate
thing that happens
so if you're at Cambridge you know that
Newton went to Cambridge and and and
milton was there and so on and and
that's how you build great institute you
get a little piece of that in your head
and you're a young person again 17 18
years old that's something that's where
I see the value of that Warren Buffett
again I think quite an extraordinary
individual I've gotten to know him I
serve on the board of the washington
post company has does warrant and i
think really a remarkable individual and
he comes back to columbia and gives
these wonderful speeches word meets with
students and so it's a it's a great a
great link you have the last one I
better make it good then Jeremy doing
seba I was wondering with the themes you
talk about side if you could kind of see
it where you see sepa sitting with that
in the future so we really i mean when
you talk about globalization the first
thing we think of is is the first thing
i think of the CEPA that's our kind of
flagship our flag into globalization and
john coatsworth who's a very
distinguished historian of latin america
has been serving as dean doing a great
job and will continue to serve and we've
designated one of the beginning five
buildings in phase 1 of manhattan ville
for the school of international public
affairs because right now it is stuck in
that 1960s 70s soviet style
building right by the the law school and
and that's that's tough so so it's on
it's on a growth then we're very
supportive of seafoam and they have some
great great programs and I would say you
know the journalism school and social
work and public health I could go on
about every single one of them as just
how how dynamic they they really are you
everybody all of us should feel very
very proud to have the connections we do
to this institution it's a stunning
stunning place so thank you lee or you
know wonderful wonderful responses to
interview questions and your engagement
so totally with this group and what
you've done for the university are proud
to have signed you up for four five more
years and and just your accomplishments
over these last nine have been
remarkable we've got a lot more to do
and we're really proud
Thank You Lee and thank you Bill I thank
you so much for coming i hope you
enjoyed the conversation with leonville
i invite you to the reception and i
invite you to the private viewing of the
anniversary show in the hasa atrium the
anniversary show 75 years of looking
forward is curated by Janet Bishop a
graduate of the Graduate School of Arts
and Sciences at Columbia it illustrates
the story of the artists collectors
cultural Mavericks and San Francisco
leaders who founded built and have
animated the museum's enjoy the rest of
the evening and thanks for coming
you